nell'episodio precedente oddio un
portale entriamo nel portare in un altro
mondo hanno fermati e lui è soltanto mio
devo decidere il finale ci si è tornati
indietro nella tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
fan i j
oggi andiamo avanti commenta terrà che
lavori con dio di salvataggi sono e non
mi ricordo che avevo salvato
probabilmente nell'ultimo 3 36 di questo
per forza allora ragazzi eravamo rimasti
che prima eravamo usciti dal portale per
la mente
c'era sto coso che ho tirato giù altro
forum ore macabro quando clicchi di
reggio andare avanti anche perché cos'è
sta roba c'è una bambola e vabbè andiamo
fuori e cioè buongiorno c'è una bambola
manichino perfetto non non disturbiamo
la lasciamo tutto lì c'è un corvo levati
da cazzo devo passare grazie grazie
mille e la morte la porta è chiusa
perfetto ragazzi non si vuole aprire
continuiamo ok
devo sfondarla a calci sponda cosa devo
fare che lo so in quale era 3 galina in
tutto questo non lo so sti posti non
siamo mica visti prima
vabbè io non ho capito dove tu che cazzo
è che succede
maria cos'è e maria è morta perfetto e
buongiorno aver fatto non è morta ma
l'edizione io che la odio questa è cos'è
questo dov'è il dottore non lo so e c'è
veramente lo so quanto voglio dire cosa
è successo a lui il dottore è morto in
poi che vorranno lui e si è morto ok
qualcosa dice che non l'ha presa bene va
bene andiamo avanti così sì comunque non
mi dispiace il fatto che è che sia
si preghi preghiamo tutti insieme anche
perché è colpa sua fine la maledizione
scomparsa e musica è tutto così canna e
papà è andato ho provato a scegliere con
discrezione ho chiuso gli occhi e sono
sicuro che andrà tutto per il meglio a
nessun altro verrà fatto levare a causa
degli esperimenti di papa non è non è in
nessun altro posto in cui andare quindi
cos'è adesso mi sto pra da dietro che
sta fa ma io ok effettivamente credo che
l'abbia stuprata a casa
ma scherziamo io stavo scherzando prima
ok mi sta veramente dio
raga io sto scherzando ma non ci credo
dottore non sei più e non sei più con
noi ma per favore prendi coprendo il
cuore io devo devi togliere non cosa
hanno capito dottore di vi aspettate non
chiamo lo aspettate un attimo
no no non sto capendo cioè no cosa non
mi dire che no scozia ma stiamo
scherzando
cioè dai dio mio voto fatto una puntata
di 30 secondi c'è maria tolto il cuore
al mio dio santissimo già finale è
questo non c'è un filmato non c'è nulla
che ma fuoco non è un finale questo ma
che i ragazzi dato che la puntata è
durata una mazza praticamente direi di
fare anche l'altro finale li facciamo
tutti insieme allora aspettate un attimo
l'altro mondo era questo perfetto
ragazzi abbiamo ricaricato prima di fare
la scelta del finale e adesso devo
andare avanti
in italia ci dovrebbe essere di nuovo la
mamma e io devo scegliere il finale è
giusto stavolta non sto rileggere tutto
perché abbiamo già fatto una volta
ok ragazzi ci dovremmo essere posso
salvare il mio padre con questa con
l'acqua santa
ma per quanto riguarda mia madre se se
il tuo amore la raggiunge sono sicuro
che trovate può essere salvata veramente
non sono così sicura quindi che cosa
dovrei fare
ragazzi ci stiamo prima ha fatto
esaudisce il desiderio di mamma adesso
facciamo salva papa tocca stronza adesso
dico io ci avrei anche un bel balcone ma
io salverò papa bene cosa è successo
siete trasportato cos'è aia che cosa
stai facendo
scusa mamma chiara me fame
ok bene ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo vince
cosa ma dio mio
lo sfregiata sta scomparendo mio corpo
sta scomparendo mamma
ahia ahia un caso che fa male ai a non
dire ayane so che fa male
no non andare ai massimi ventilato
l'acqua addosso
è una scena triste slow motion qua
dovreste piange ragazzi pian piangete
piangete tutti
e scomparso si in perfetto grazie a lei
che sia così scontento alla fine cioè
alla fine va bene e ce l'abbiamo fatta
abbiamo salvato il maniaco papà è morto
messo ha visto un cazzo oddio adesso è
vivo e vivi perfetta cosa sono stato
salvato aia sito salvato io abbracciami
papà papà aia
scusami aia so che sei stata preoccupata
per me non l'ha interrotto ma non
importa
ma no attenti dietro ai a non volevo
farti sapere la verità ma con l'ultimo
mio potere oddio che è successo sono
entrato cosa cosa sta facendo a vuole
farmi scoprire la verità un qualcosa che
non sapevo prima cosa vieni maria
dottore che è successo cosa si stanno
abbracciando ragazza diventando vietate
18 sosta gameplay dottore cos'è lei non
sa della nostra relazione
cosa più cosa vorrebbe dire lei non si
fida di me questo è il problema
la ragazza diventerà undicenne presto
quindi in un'età problematica sono
sicuro si gentile con lei per favore
assicurati che stia sempre assicura il
mio bene più prezioso la sbagliata e la
più preziosa bambola che ho tra tutte
cosa cos'è una bambola io papà
cos'è successo sta diventa è diventata
una bambola check cosa cosa adesso si
scopre che hai a una bambola questo è
successo adesso arriva la mamma sono
sicura ecco infatti mamma non puoi
prenderlo non ha mai visto un film
fantasmi tipo ghost dove non puoi
parlare con i presenti no non dirmi che
con quella ragazza ancora la sta facendo
lista spiandola solid snake si sta
mettendo trovare voglio trasformarla
nella più bella bambola che posso cosa
trasformarla in una bambola mamma che
cosa vuol dire non permettono ormai che
la nostra precisa figlia venga
trasformata in una venga utilizzata
comunali più soggetti oddio no entrata
merda qua si mette male tu cosa intendi
dire sai sta pianificando un esperimento
su di lei ha quindi hai sentito non ti
farò fare quello che vuoi con lei
oh cazzo mamma
no ma no cosa oh mio dio ma cosa ma
questa è da censura ragazzi non è ma no
cosa o mio dio mamma no no ma no
bene resto non è mio zio santissimo
maria falco e cosa mila di milady resta
con noi a maria non era proprio così
stronzo alla fine dottore perchè l'hai
fatto e doveva essere fatto per il
futuro di aia ora dobbiamo riuscire a
nascondere il corpo
naturalmente aia non deve vederlo
ragazzi e questo è più brutto del cev
accordi prima era il be danny cioè
finale cattivo questo ancora più brutto
cazzo c'è ma dai
mamma preferivo come finiva prima
sinceramente dico sì mio dio e questo e
sottili che questo è soltanto un sogno è
soltanto un brutto sogno
eh no non è un sogno oh mio dio si è
svegliata questa realtà mamma devi
correre via via da lui
ok aia ok cazzo sta diventando brutta
faccenda aia cosa che non va perché
sembri così spaventata la tuo padre no
va via
maledetto no che dice sa o cazzo
è bene quindi quello che ho visto era la
verità papà tu non pensi che tua madre
sia così fantastica volevo soltanto un
po più di tempo ma papà volevi trasformi
in una bambola non essere triste aia
facendoti diventando facendo seguono
fantastico facendo di diventare una
bambola saresti diventata bella per
sempre ed è tutto il frutto della mia
ricerca oddio mio ragazzo
questo non ebbe finale a qualcosa di
loro si sta muovendo diventerò come
l'oro vieni qui vicino a tuo padre
no sta rifiutando tuo padre scusami ma
io non voglio diventare una bambola ok
sto scappa raga è diventata via corvo la
il cazzo via devo scappare e di brutto e
chiusa perché non si apre a prima porta
aria cazzo apre grazie raga non si apre
prima doveva ok
a bridge proprio addio via via di qui
eccesso
raga farnese ambienti sa cos'è porca
[ __ ] ragazzi questo nascerà fantozzi a
praga ioso bene questa è una scena
bruttissima e affettivo l'edizione bene
bene merda merda cazzo ragazzi aiuta
cosa ok giusto facciamo mio dio aperto
la porta
ho aperto la porta come torni indietro a
cazzo e non posso andare di là si va
bene devo devo schivarlo se ce l'ho
fatta
vai calcio carri beh dove 62 esce cosa
cosa è successo sono ritornata dottore
aiutata arrivare a scappa maria non
lasciare che gaia scappi maria fammi
passare che ti dire un cazzotto perfetto
aspetta aspetta una minchia carie dove
vai
cosa posso fare non lo so vai a sinistra
a destra sinistra
ok grandissima perfetto ragazzi sta
diventando salva salva salva ragazza
diventando questa è una cosa assurda
cioè nomi non mi sarei mai aspettato un
finale del genere cioè perché non si
apre non si apre niente sto posto come
ci siamo arrivati qui se sono tutte
chiuse le porte
cosa devo fare non lo so das quinas con
i tipi la salute qui potrei la sua mamma
mia che genio raga non ci credo al primo
colpo stavolta è bene sta arrivando
qualcuno
padrona e qui non sono qui ma ci sono
stato al mondo marcio [ __ ] è arrivato
il cazzutissimo è dov'è andata ya mi
scusi l'ho persa di vista cosa sola mi
scuso terribilmente sono certo che non
può essere andata tanto lontana
dovremmo cercarla 6 inutile oddio non ci
non ci credo c'è io gli ha tagliato
aspettate
no no ma che cazzo
beh maria ho detto è ancora vivo come
cazzo fa essere viva che la squartata in
due dottore maria ragazzi cosa dovrei
fare c'è troppo sangue ma vorresti
salvarla dopo che voleva a prenderti c'è
qualcosa che posso usare ma cosa che ti
volevo uccidere prendi quella come band
ha però non penso che questo tipo ben da
noi infatti siamo un dottore pessimo
vabbè c'è qualcosa qui non lo so asti
qual caso trovato c'è qualcosa qui ha
detto la mia stessa frase mi sta
copiando ragazza è diventata a perfetto
band non so se li ha segato la testa
cosa ma di sicuro si è fatta male e
parecchio delle bende posso posso
fasciati attorno al corpo a posto dottor
house ha colpito magolfa lo zio e il
piacere gli ha tirato una motosega ed è
in piedi cioè affermato il sangue
padrona ti ringrazio per aver pero st
presa cura di me non ti preoccupare è
tutto a posto ho portato via tutto
quello che amavi di sicuro mi odierà i
ma devi essere così gentile per mostrare
a me così tanta compassione ancora maria
in effetti io non l'avrei fatto però
break maria può essere poi leggerti
padrona
andiamo usciamo da qui insieme va bene
la shopper maria
oddio è svenuta scusami padrona fosse
appoggiarmi alla tua spalla
certo devo farla uscire a yo yo comando
fantastico
fammi salvare ragazzi sta diventando c'è
ma io devo andare dato mandato il padre
noi andrei dalla parte opposta papa sta
ancora guardando in giro infatti va
dalla parte cosa va bene se fossi andato
a destra invece oh mio dio
avete fatto qua bene sta diventato io
devo andare per uscire dall altra parte
raga ma se arriva il padre son cazzi
patrona presto devo occorre ragazzi mi
sa che sta arrivando maledizione è
caduta a te maria padrona non
preoccuparti di mais k
no ce ne andremo insieme per favore
adesso lasciami ragazzi no cosa no ma
perché ma che rispetto ai per i corpi
altrui
devo che poi tra l'altro non è tanto
lontano e qui quindi devo scappare
ragazzi scappiamo adesso sta arrivando
di sicura è cazzo non avevo e ho trovata
è come faccio
beh ragazzi è uno scontro uno contro uno
non si apre la porta maledizione a siti
aperta meno 6 in chat si presenta
nathalie cos'è chi è questa cosa è
successo
vieni qui con noi no oddio vaso è
spuntato deve tener ti fermano aia io ti
voglio bene
cazzola ragazzi non mi dite no papà che
è successo chi è mai a papà io ti voglio
bene ai a chi è che gli sta lanciando
coltelli ti prego dimmi che maria che
lancio ha coltelli anche alle persone
giuste per una volta sei brava si legge
ancora in piedi grandissima è un'esperta
lanciatrice di coltelli comunque
l'abbiamo notato grande grande maria ok
questa è commovente manda papà non si
muove e meno male
il papà è morto lo spero padrona non
c'era nessun altra scelta per
proteggerti credo che non sia morto
ragazzi è mosso si è mosso o in questo
c'è un coltello mentre addio a lui è
tornato fantastico meno male quando
serve torna ci si muoveva ancora con tre
coltelli nel corpo e uno in testa c'è
cos'è questa cosa è successo penso sia
finita dio mio
raga e stata una cosa incredibile siamo
all'entrata c'è anche fiocco di neve
ebbene ci hai salvato ti ringrazio ma
c'è qualcosa che devo fare prima di
andarmene ed è dare fuoco a questa casa
perché tutte le mie tutti mi ricordi
felici sono qui dentro
ma è l'unica possibilità per far per far
sparire le tracce di tuo padre da qui
non possiamo lasciare che la stessa
tragedia si ripeta ancora direi che
possiamo salutarci
ok ragazze andando tutto a fuoco così a
caso c'è lo sguardo infiammante c'è
peggio di chuck norris
ok bene addio a yara oramai e ok ragazzi
stiamo andando
siamo forse finalmente usciti dalla casa
maledetta se ce l'abbiamo fatta bene sto
andando tutto a fuoco mi dispiace però
per lui che non può c'è la fine morirà
porca vacca cosa cos'è che cosa cos'è
questo sono finalmente oddio e ai alla
grande ho sentito molto parlare di
questo posto la clinica travis e fuori
nel mezzo del nulla nessuno noterebbe
ceo non c'entrerei comunque a
prescindere se fuori nel mezzo del nulla
comunque va beh già che ci sei ea
bongiorno che hanno questa ai alla
grande cosa ha un paziente benvenuta ho
chiesto al mio dottore di fare un check
up ma come posso dire la mia famiglia è
veramente povera quindi il dottore non
mi ha dato aiuti ed è per questo che
sono venuto qui ho sentito che il
dottore act che vive separato al
controlli gratuiti
sì noi non chiediamo soldi per i nostri
pazienti non devo farlo però l'ho fatto
a non semi messa molto bene ma miti
visitare prima possibile
vieni dentro da ora non soffrirai più
quindi sta tranquilla e va a dormire c'è
anche jaric e maria sa cosa fa maria
l'app riporta nel retro da padrona e
proprio come te fa parte della famiglia
cosa se devo essere sincero raga mi
sarei aspettato che anche aias quarta se
la gente se devo essere sincero
però non è finita così fortunatamente
quindi ragazzi ho fatto due finali
tintoria ce ne sarebbe un terzo
raccogliendo tutte le gemme di finale
speciale ma se lo farò lo farò più
avanti se volete che lo faccia comunque
fatemelo sapere altrimenti la finisco
qui per me non è un problema è stato
fantastico medi father devo essere
sincero di sicuro vi sicuro farò
un'altra serie gdr tipo medi father
giochi del genere tipo mizhuo per fare
un esempio
adesso vedono bene cosa fare comunque ne
farò altri state tranquilli
quindi niente ragal come al solito se vi
dove è piaciuto lasciato un commento mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
in ogni video trovate nella descrizione
serra seta con i siti scrivete vende ci
vediamo un prossimo video bella ragazzi